1er pierre bédier et nathalie pereira
2684 la joie de leur soutien à l'
annonce des résultats en mairie de
mantes-la-jolie ce dimanche 20 juin
pierre bédier nathalie pereira première
adjointe de mantes la ville se classe à
la première position de ce premier tour
des élections départementales dans le
canton le binôme du président sortant
les républicains du conseil
départemental ensemble pour les yvelines
obtient 37,19 % des voix un score plus
élevé que lors du scrutin de 2015 par
rapport à la dernière élection
départementale on progresse de presque 2
points donc c'est quand même pas mal
une abstention record et tous les autres
grands partis recul et en particulier le
front national on sera contre le front
national au deuxième tour mais un front
national qui a perdu huit points en six
ans ce qui est d'ailleurs logique
puisque quand le front national gouverne
il déçoit c'est ce qui s'est passé avant
que la ville est donc après il faut dans
ce canton rejouera effectivement au
second tour le duel de 2015 entre pierre
bédier cyril note pour le rn l'ancien
maire de mantes la ville et mathilde
andraud est ex responsable départemental
du rassemblement national ont récolté 21
19% des suffrages
le binôme est d'ailleurs arrivé en tête
dans trois des cinq communes de ce
canton de 80000 habitants ont subi
l'abstention on suit en tête dans trois
communes soit 5 e magnanville buchelay
et mantes la ville
je bats pierre bédier de 75 voix malgré
malgré le fait que son binôme soit la
première adjointe de nantes la ville
donc ça me fait effectivement
extrêmement plaisir j'en profite pour
remercier chaleureusement les et
mandeville ouest cela démontre que tous
les manduellois ne sont pas ne sont pas
à vendre à 500 voix derrière le
rassemblement national à la candidature
de l'union de la gauche qui rassemblait
la france insoumise europe ecologie les
verts et le parti socialiste
audrey alliés dylan guelton ne
parviennent pas à accéder au second tour
16 88% une seconde place à signaler dans
la commune de mantes-la-jolie
satisfaction de ce point de vue mais
frustration tout de même de ne pas avoir
réussi à rassembler davantage suis très
fier de sa deuxième maman que l'algérie
troisième sur le canton
et c'est bien la preuve qu'
effectivement ce dès ce projet d'union
on avait depuis le départ aujourd'hui
les payant effectivement il ya une
partie frustration et colère parce que
parce que certaines personnes n'ont pas
compris effectivement l'enjeu de cette
union là nous ont tourné le dos dans le
viseur le parti communiste qui n'a pas
rejoint l'union deux candidats de cette
sensibilité était d'ailleurs en course
dans deux binômes différents martin sort
est en lice avec jean philippe blot
totalise 5 24 % des bulletins 5,0 4%
pour le duo du conseiller d'opposition
de mantes la jolie marque jamais et
binta sip
enfin la candidature de la république en
marge de khadija mounib et d'alain le
cas ma récolte 12 31% des voix dernier
de ce scrutin du premier tour julie et
andré et jacques le fer avec 2,15 pour
cent un canton de mantes la jolie où la
participation s'est élevée à seulement
27 52 % au premier tour soit plus de 13
points en moins par rapport à 2015